add handling at scale requires a
combination of millions of requests
rapid bids and serving the ads
themselves join us as we talk to unity
about how they've built out their ad
system on this episode stack chat thanks
for joining us TJ
tell us a little bit more about what
unity does thanks mark
unity builds a high-definition 3d
real-time graphics rendering engine and
it's used in game development platforms
as well as a variety of other
applications like automotive
architecture and film on the game
development side we have a number of
back-end services to support game
publishers in particular the part I'm
involved in its monetization and we have
in-app purchase services as well as ad
services so yeah I'd love to hear more
about how the architecture actually
supports all of the ad requests that
come in for a game so we get about tens
of thousands of ab requests a second so
it's pretty high volume and those all go
into a public gke cluster and that
service also makes bid requests to third
parties and rate of about a million a
second
those requests are all public IP
addresses so that we can get good
performance and going to those bidders
we had tried to dine out on that and
that didn't work as well
additionally we have a private UK
cluster it were all over support
services run for security reasons and
they're only that cluster is only
accessible internally and we also have
virtual machines that are running a
variety of databases that also might
work for our own network
additionally we have data that's going
into knots and Kafka before hitting
other parts of our system and we have
logging going to stock tremor what are
some of the other parts of the system
that Kafka sends the data to so other
parts of the system are billing business
intelligence and some machine learning
systems that make trained ones that are
used for making decisions that various
stages within around the world
so was this architecture built natively
on GCP or was it migrated from somewhere
else we migrated from another cloud
provider into GCP about a year ago and
in the prior environment we had a lot of
services that were on bear first
machines got some machining services and
crannies we had a variety of different
CI city processes so early on in the
migration process we did some
engineering work to figure out how we
would migrate our services we wanted to
have a consistent cid c CI c d pipeline
for all of our services in chesapeake
and so we loved the pre-work was to
upgrade the CI c d pipeline for all of
our services to be standardized and that
pipeline also supported the GCP
migration additionally getting the
ad-serving
component migrated over required
solving a couple of technical problems
around DNS and just the volume of
traffic that we have so now that you've
got all this up and running in GCP are
there any changes that you would make or
if you could go back would you do
anything differently we're pretty happy
with the structure we have in GCP right
now being on a standardized CI CT
pipeline has been really helpful for us
it makes it easy to deploy new services
we have a process for doing that in
particular changes that we're making in
our migrating towards manage database
services like they break and drop in
some of our more customized database
systems sounds good well thank you so
much for coming in today and telling us
a little bit about how you built the add
request Network great to be here thanks
check out this deep dive on building an
advertising platform on Google cloud
platform thanks for watching and make
sure to subscribe for more great Google
cloud platform content we'll see you
next time on snapchat
[Music]
you